welcome to this video this is the last
video in a series about my my your
current tournament it's only eight
videos because um I will cover the final
two rounds in this one video the thing
is and i will tell that right away in 19
i played a very quick draw which was
basically no game so i will show it
briefly at the end but it's simply a
pointless to make a single video out of
a 9 move game and i would also explain
to you why this really wasn't a full
font game this ninth round but let's get
to round eight first because this was a
it was an interesting full game yay
around eight at this at that point it
was clear that i couldn't score
grandma's norm anymore on it was very
tough in the first place but by that
moment it was even mathematically
impossible even with two wins in round 8
and roll 9i gotten to seven out of nine
which is a fantastic score but it still
wouldn't be enough to to get to this
desire 2600 performance rating it's
simply very tougher demand this 2600 um
so this was this game was basically yeah
let's say a freeroll i wanted to of
course i'd like to win but it's not like
i needed to do anything i needed to to
to to go along go all out for win and
just wanted to play and see what happens
however and this is interesting for the
cause of the game my opponent um younger
spanish play i called them don't let me
confuse this what's the what's his first
name santiago santiago gonzalez still at
aura gonzalez de Latour it is not
visible in the name is too long for and
for the SEC software he's a younger
Spanish player rated 2400 I think 60 60
or slightly below that and
he still had the chance to score grandma
sanam he had the same point as I had but
he had um some better opponents in the
first rounds so he at least
theoretically with two wins could still
do it so it was clear to me that he
probably wanted to win the game I mean
you always want to win but he really had
a big big goal with with the wind
connected so um this was interesting for
the cause of the game okay i went for
Knight f3 on in my preparation which was
not that thorough I must admit because
that day we had made a long long trip
around the island so I didn't take very
long time to prepare him I saw that he
mostly played the Slav and well I did
basically do a coin toss if I start with
D for an idea three at the end i went
for 93 and he had here always plates his
6 in my prep and after that after c6 I
had planned I mean he didn't do that but
I had planned to play a one of those
queen bee three quincy two lines that
you probably have seen me play in and
blitz as well however now he played e6
hmm was a perfectly good move but i
didn't expect the specific move autumn
and now i had a slight slight problem um
I am I don't like very much to play you
can play it but I didn't want to go for
this without any preparation without
knowing what line he is playing and yeah
bout this I also would like to play but
I had had seen in the prep that he had
played this yeah from another move water
of course from the sloth move order so
he had played this a number of times and
after this he had taken
so yeah I wasn't sure what to do now
after this e 6 of course I can play the
Catalan but yeah at the end I decided to
play Bishop g5 which is an interesting
move on a trick trick it's not like like
is tricked into something terrible but
it's just it's an interesting way to to
deviate what's the point yeah if he
wants to play em yeah something that is
not a declined Queens gambit like Bishop
e7 then black now um yeah needs to yeah
not a good very good sentence how do I
start him okay he's not playing Bishop
e7 it's not in his repertoire but the
semi slab is in his repertoire like with
c6 however c6 now I can play can play
here or I can also play here and cover
c4 so we cannot play the bod Vinick yeah
this this capture on c4 if he takes now
on c4 I have an additional idea with
Queen a for check just regaining the
pawn yeah keep it keep it simple
approach yeah and what else is there the
the the main way that the semi sloth
players handle this is aged 6 and this
is what he played and after that I could
take and play into this line this is
what happened in the game um and this is
a line that he hadn't played before he
had played this this pod v-neckline with
an early capture on see form so i
thought maybe ok i don't know much about
this but maybe his knowledge is also
limited the the funny thing is yeah well
I really didn't know any specific theory
here only from what I had seen in Grand
Master games and slow we managed to play
out 20 moves of theory quite remarkable
um ok III covering c4 and he went 97
Bishop d3 yeah white
and you has tries to yeah sort of play
for a tempo gain so that you can
probably take with one in one move on c4
but black has various waiting moves as
well so Bishop d3 this is the absolute
mainline he captured and now played g6
yeah this is the the modern way to play
this I mean modern from the early 90's i
would say in former years they very
often played with bishop d 6 cm and then
you five at some stage but g6 is
probably just the better move the idea
is to set up a position like that Bishop
on g7 can put these moves on the board
the bishop on g7 the Queen on f6 is of
course slightly misplaced we're very
often just dropped back to e7 and then
the bishop is nicely placed on g7 it can
support an e5 move and c5 move and
always note that black has the bishop
pan so long term black is probably in
quite good shape the short term
compensation however for wide is that
white has a very very nice quick
development and good central control now
can play a form which I did in fact this
combination of e for an early look see
one is already a sideline but I really I
really didn't know what what the exact
term move orders are here I knew that
there are moves like that book see one
rookie one and I just tried to play play
natural moves putting things in the
center yeah Queenie seven is some
normal-looking move rook da this also
played it seems what I am yeah I looked
at this later obviously I really didn't
know anything yeah rookie one
centralizing this piece and I really
remember that this is sometimes played
it's another in another position though
I can confuse the matters I think
generally speaking if you want hint what
to do probably the direct you Forrester
is the most interesting way to play this
is how it is done in most games and
nowadays yeah okay we played this Luke
c1 and he went rook t8 yet he had dawned
on me that maybe this isn't too great
what what I said up here the ruckus
opposite opposite the Queen and yeah
well ok I need to move the Queen
probably so I went to e2 that's not the
only move it seems but it had been
played before I mean finally enough I
discovered that there are games with
this position and even a couple of more
moves unknown yeah here he played the
immediate c5 um yeah I cannot say it
surprised me but I was more yeah
reckoning with be six or a six these
kind of ideas trying to expand on the
queenside and only then play see five
but c5 is perfectly good I mean no no
question afternoon like b6 that comes
into consideration too yeah at some
stage maybe just exchange with Bishop a
six no and get rid of the get rid of the
bishop am the other ideas for general
setup is like 'if I've and putting the
bishop on e4 however white always must
be very careful with those kind of
advances the pawn on e5 can also prove
to be a liability in the long run as the
sea porn and the deep on maybe get
exchanged at some point after ç five and
then if there is no deep on e5 can
easily become a weakness attacked by the
night and take by the bishop it's a it's
a very young very young very tricky
business sometimes as it once he went c5
however and it's a perfectly normal move
and has been played before yeah d5
pretty much a given I have
no other move really um yeah I cannot I
mean the promise I need to have some
compensation for the bishop pair and in
a symmetric position like this it can
easily happen that black long-term can
use his bishops with a 6b 6b should be
seven and so on so my idea was that
after d5 it's yeah I'm threatening d
take c6 and black plays Knight b6 which
is the the most natural move this should
be 385 this was played and it's by
father the most logical continuation
this happened and now my compensation
for the two bishops is that I have a
very strong bishop on d5 and it's pretty
much impossible for black to ignore this
piece you almost have to exchange it
with Bishop b6 which is what he did um
you on there also you don't have any way
to develop an official I mean if you are
very stubborn and try to to keep it yeah
you can play yeah rook b8 mb6 Bishop d7
is still in exchange you simply have no
place to put the bishop without having
it exchange which would be six is just
the natural move yeah and here it's
quite funny I actually really found a
game with this position so we played 18
moose of of known theory in a way
without knowing it he also said that it
felt very natural to him but um not like
he knew that it was was played before
and he I'm playing the novelty without
knowing it was a novelty and I honestly
believe that my move was somewhat
stronger than the Moose that has been
played before the game that is that had
reached this position is actually very
high level game white white player was a
German top player are to you support
playing white against former champion
vishy anand in a Bundesliga game German
leak 2006
and use a puff played Quincy for and
this is I think just weaker than mine
why played queen bee hive and I'm not
quite sure how your the poem came to
Quincy for because it's pretty pretty
straight forward now Alan took on be to
Quincy 525 Luke c5 to go on d5 ed 557
and here you can can already assess that
black is just better not by much but
it's pretty pretty clear that black is
for choice d 5 is a weakness not a
strength and black ass got the bishop
against the somewhat clumsy night and
aunt went on to win a pretty nice game
quickly even only 40 moves or 40
something moves not quite sure I mean I
briefly thought about Quincy for but
when I when I saw Queen B 5 it was
pretty clear to me that this must be the
better news it's just more active the
queen is protecting be too and the
following is this is pretty much forced
of course why it's not playing for an
advantage anymore my rooks e1 e1
business is just just not the most
precise way to play black hand here if
he wants equalize relatively easily um
with with the capture here now this is a
very very simple solution that equalizes
the game like this takes Queen d7 and
now it at xt5 yeah rook c5 is the way to
go b6 green textbook takes rook see to
rock g5 v three and we have a pretty
much debt equal position yeah black has
a slide symbolic advantage with the
bishop ur can go to see 5 which there is
nothing happening here
I just played g3 rook 1 2 e 2 I just I
just stay and do nothing and it will end
in a draw the difference to the user /
violent game is that here there is a
totally symmetric upon structure the d5
pawn was a weakness in there here there
is no d5 pawn is just totally
symmetrical um but ok as mentioned he
wanted to win the game and preserve at
least winning chances so this wasn't his
intention he played them in this
position he played rook c8 and this is
also better I mean just black is the 12
to try at the moment with the two
bishops and there's no one no reason for
him to to to sort of yeah trade it down
to a draw ok ya hear the heel is
interesting ok what I could pretty
quickly rule out is taking on b7 yeah
something like this is just very unlucky
idea or even Queen takes it leads to a
big activity on black spot and the past
see porn so this is no real idea yeah
and there is more than one way to play
what i did i think is interesting i took
only six Queenie 6 and yeah here white
has a choice i added calculate rook
takes e5 which is of course the most
obvious move but i didn't like it very
much and i was attracted to another idea
however look c5 seems to be ok i can
show you what irritated me this this
particular line was some was irritating
me Queen a2 um yeah b2 is hanging so I
probably need to play Queen c7 attacking
the rook and then something like that
say rook e8 Queen B seven Bishop b2 this
position um yeah I really didn't like
because it looks like that the a pawn
can be a serious problem however
with moves like Queen d7 here why does
getting lots of activity with the Queen
and probably he has no serious problem
the point is on a 7 it's very far behind
and it seems that let's say let's say
black place Brooke the ATF for example
then stuff like a five and a six can can
secure enough counter play now it's it's
probably a no no real problem I was
attracted to another idea though I mean
when I saw the movie I thought well this
is interesting why not try this I played
'if I've here and this this has some
some nice ideas it cuts off the bishop
of course sorry it cuts off the bishop
so that it cannot take on b2 of be
active and in any way and it also does a
very good job of restricting blacks
Queen the problem is if black moves the
Queen at some point then my ez pawn is
even advancing further and really
opening up the position to my advantage
so um let's just for the general idea if
black plays something like we need seven
it does not make much sense but I want
to show the idea apply six and he needs
to do something that he does not want to
do like capturing and weakening the
whole who would structure or yeah this
is even more terrible problem
establishing a pass or 96 Queenie seven
assists made does the Sun make any sense
in this position but it's a general idea
it's also why black gum is almost never
able to take here for example and then
then e6 can get very tricky for asking
position so I like the idea and I felt
that I should have a decent decent
enough position here without any any big
problems however one problem is you know
played b6 and what exactly are you doing
in terms of active players white I
didn't really see anything
it was I think a good position to to
hold it but it's not a position for
white where you can do anything great in
terms of active play a problem is simply
that you cannot contest the D file if
you look at this here you can just take
move like g6 well it's totally pointless
with the rukon d1 so I cannot fight for
the D file and yeah you cannot force the
Queen away from his six so that you can
actually push ePHI v6 it's basically a
white now employing a sit and wait
tragedy but I didn't mind that so much
because what I knew he wants to win in
some way we must try to generate winning
chances and this is often not a bad
policy if you know that the other side
is coming at you anyway to just yeah set
up a good flexible defensive position
and hope to to play for for for
counter-strike at some point ok I played
age for which is not an attacking move
but also a defensive move because my
back rank was somewhat weak of course
the right moment there also might be h4
h5 but that's nothing pruning that will
happen too quickly yeah what is some
blacks idea what you would like to do is
of course try to set his pawns in motion
but it said it's not easy to do on the
his pawns I mean the three against two
here but at the moment the White Queen
know not to be 450 the white queen is
doing quite a decent oops what am I
doing here quite a decent job of
locating the light squares um yeah he
played a rook c7 here and intending to
double on the dhitha this is of course
black Strom card he's got the
but at the moment it's not apparent what
this is actually I'm doing frame you can
go to d3 with the rook long-term but you
cannot enter on d to my knight on f3 is
just tying the positioner together in a
way ya b3 now plate I just want to make
sure that there's never between takes a
two and blocking c4s bomb it's just a
move that belongs in to this pollution
rook d7 and Queen a4 yeah this is was a
dual purpose movement wants to keep some
pressure on a 7 and maybe I can can
switch the Queen over 2f form or to e4
not a bad place for the Queen yeah he
played a 5 not an easy decision but he
thought that long-term he needs to make
this rook a mobile peace cannot be tied
to the a7 pawn for all that much longer
um but I really think that this is the
kind of position where it's very tough
to make any M any progress it would be
interesting to maybe look at this with
with a very very strong player if there
is some idea left but I really thought
we both felt that there isn't isn't much
I was basically implying a wait and sit
and wait strategy as you seek will be
five Queen 84 but yeah I was just
basically saying okay you're the one
needs to win show me and well he
shuffled a bit and try to provoke things
but there is really not much happening
yeah I went rook c2 intending to play
rook see to eat you or maybe if possible
trying to exchange one pair of rooks
that happened can't we should look a bit
at this position with one pair of rooks
traded I must say that I got somewhat
optimistic here that maybe I can
actually do something there are
scenarios that could be really favorable
for me but it's difficult to actually
reach them on the board um for example
if you look at this position and just
turn
for the moment ignore the fact that
black is attacking a 5 with the whole
pieces then you can easily imagine a
situation where white is making progress
for example I just put this on the bot
he played him you played this move um
let's just say does something like that
and what I'm doing now does not make
much sense because II five hangs right
but i just want to show what I'm what i
would like to set up something like this
ya like it like it's just moving
nonsense i just want to show there for
example something like this a night on
c4 yeah it's a very nice piece it is
supported by the pawn it detects b6 and
with a for you block the b7 the b6 b5
advanced this exam for example would be
very nice for white but it's simply not
possible to get on the board as black as
attacking if life with all pieces on the
other hand i would also like to exchange
maybe the rooks here to maybe get the
default or invade there but this also
tricky se5 is hanging we see that after
Luke d3 and a couple of more moves here
Queen g4 was good reply intending Quincy
eight so he went back yeah the Queen
trade is not helping me at all I wanted
to preserve my my active Queen him yeah
this was just sit and wait yeah auntie
rookie three the idea of rookie 3 was
twofold I wanted to get rook d3 into the
equation and also support a for that be
3s is protected and term yeah Bishop f8
the old the other idea was I wanted to
rock d7a was the last month that looked
like he wanted to play Queen d5 and in
fact he wanted to but at the last moment
here he saw that this would would have
led to disaster 25
would have been punished with e6 the
nice point being that the trade TM is no
trade as I can take d7 and just win it's
quite nice not difficult to see but
still still nice with Ruby aids and d8
Queen am getting a new queen so he would
have needed to take here now Queen Queen
texts of course check and losing the
Queen and after that I can take g6 and
have an excellent position yeah so in a
way the the essence of this e five moves
that at some point i geti 6n but he
recognized this at the late moment he
was close to playing it Bishop f8 we
both didn't have any time left ya need
to be aware of this tag control night 90
minutes for the whole game in 30 seconds
increment and by that time we were down
to some minutes each not not quite sure
how much but very little three or four
minutes or something so a for ya want to
fix the pawns Bishop g7 yeah the problem
is always how do I actually make
progress it would be excellent to get
something like this and I just show it
and if black now is doing absolutely
nothing yeah and ignoring everything i
know we five hangs but this kind of
position for example would be fantastic
for white yeah i just play against the
weakness and ts0 play but you don't ever
get to it because II five is the problem
right after the rook trade here like
we'll take a five and it's just equal
absolutely no way to make any headway
now the queen is always protecting here
I can of course play something like that
and get the pawn back with the with a
dead equal position but there is no way
to play for win yeah this is also a
rocket III wasn't played I just played
King edge too and we we shuffled
shuffled a bit more
I only add had 11 funny idea we repeated
and now and now at this moment no here I
needed to go to age too because I had
one idea and this is what I tried
actually I played a rook to e1 he went
through t7 and here I had an idea and I
was I was spotting at the last moment
that it is not working my idea here was
it's quite nice for creativity but
simply not working what's the same check
check on a eight yeah he can play Bishop
fa di but let's say place king age 7 and
then my idea for us to play yeah what's
the play rookie form intending to answer
queen bee three with 95 takes takes
Andrew H for checkmate that's funny
right also why I needed to have the King
on edge too so that queen d 5 is not
possible the only problem is black has
rock before and I'm just totally lost so
this idea yeah created with the very
little time on the clock was totally
nonsense fortunately and I recognize
this after rookie one Luke d7 yeah I
played rookie 3 and this is actually a
three-fold repetition and he claimed to
draw here I honestly I wanted to
continue but I simply at this moment I
was irritated that I had overlooked this
rock t4 move and this tactic so yeah I
wanted to just play move quickly and
played rookie three it's the logical
move and it's a draw but I really wanted
to continue a bit but it's just a bit
easier from wide to play this position
but I'm objectively speaking there is
nothing happening really I mean I was I
wasn't sure really if there is some way
to to continue on because there's always
this idea that those
horns are fixed on dark squares and the
bishop on g7 but on the other hand
there's always the e5 pawn being a
weakness I have really no way for what
black has the D file I did some analysis
on this and it seems that it's really
just totally equal um yeah not not much
that you can do it's not a very exciting
game but it sometimes just happens i
mean i stumbled into this opening line
that i didn't really know very well and
after this there is really not much else
to play for them to to get this flexible
defensive position that maybe you can
use for for counter-attack but I'm
pretty much okay with this I mean not a
good opening result but after that I
think we both played a very very decent
game okay um what now for the for the
last round the ninth round what you need
to know is and this is also a reason why
this game in the ninth round was was so
short I can I need to set up a new board
him okay new board why the game was so
shortest the eighth round game was
played in the evening as our rounds were
played and we finished the game about 30
minutes past midnight and after that we
usually am had like one or two beers and
and and and ate a bit because you
couldn't really eat before the round so
in essence you got into bed at two or
three o'clock in this case it was close
to three o'clock and the last round was
played at nine thirty in the morning so
just six hours about six hours past
bedtime and in my specific case it also
meant that it was not nine o'clock to
get up but about seven o'clock because
we needed to pack our suitcases and so
on so I had a zero preparation and like
four hours of sleep
feel this is on the long and this on the
far side of it probably it was even less
than four hours so last round I got
black against grand master galleygo
galleygo from Portugal Grandmaster with
24 70 or something rating and he played
in four and yeah I had to only look like
a couple of minutes before and I saw
that against these moves he always plays
sidelines he does not play the open he
plays moves like g3 and and things like
that I need to enter examine mode him
just not working just just a moment
sorry so he always played sidelines
mostly some stuff like g3 which is not
very a very dangerous really and this is
what i liked to play us like no problem
he played 93 however which was quite
quite curious didn't expect that yeah i
wasn't sure what to do now I didn't want
to play Knight f6 here with e 5 coming
possibly not a bad line for black but I
didn't didn't really know that I went
here because I thought well he does not
play the open anyway and if you would
have done so okay I have some ideas um
he went Bishop b5 in this position just
staying within the territory of them off
of entire Sicilians not open to Sian um
yeah I wasn't sure what to do here I
didn't know it but I went 45 and I think
this is a good move it has been played
before by some strong player so not not
a problem at all yeah he he he captured
on c6 very early probably not
waiting like 97 where I cover the the
night to recapture with the peace he
took them now played d3 okay very solid
set up for white went Bishop e7 um and
here on he played the moose age three
probably preventing Bishop g4 young well
here I wasn't sure should I play Knight
f6 I don't know I always think that the
move f5 is the way to go here for black
if you are not in danger of being hit
with a quick c3 and deform I think you
should play a five and i did so he took
click night you form regrouping the
night to g3 and then allowing this
opening procedure play tonight f6 and
with this move over the draw which was
accepted so as I said not a real game of
chess but the thing is with three or
four hours and eight rounds every ever
felt I was totally tired and don't
forget I'm playing black against the
Grandmaster so it's not like I refuse to
play against some some weaker player
that I could could could be easily or
anything it's always a bit of a shame
that you don't take the chance to play
against the GM but I was so tired
absolutely no chance so we both were
basically glad that the tournament was
over he accepted that and just with two
words or three words it's too early yeah
and it really what it was really early
with all those further rounds being
played and the little time for for sleep
that that there was um alright i hope
you enjoyed the overall coverage let me
just sum up briefly at six points at the
end out of nine games which was very
nice results given the level of the
opposition i absolutely a beat all
opponents with the lower rating there
were only three of them when who were
lower rated and I beat them and against
the the ims with the buff 2400 they all
go
let's say stronger iams and then I am
now like to 472 460 of this kind of
players and against the GM sir I played
the fifty percent score beating Aquinas
the GM from Lithuania with lucky game
but okay I lost against saludando chenko
he played very strong gamer thought and
all the other games ended in draws where
I mostly was wasn't in any any big
danger I was some mostly fine throughout
the game so I'm very satisfied with the
results there is really no no use for
second thoughts should I have done this
or that the only thing that um feels bad
that I didn't find the right
continuation in the round six game
against cream mascarpone which we're
with them the real-time g4 i think i
would have had excellent chances to win
the game which would yeah would have
been very interesting in terms of the
overall tournament as then with the five
out of six i would have gotten one of
the absolute top guys in the tournament
and it's always interesting to play
those kind of games you never know
what's going to happen um yeah this is
only the only point everything okay here
that I could have done something much
better and and differently ok I hope you
enjoyed the serious I got lots of
positive feedback for it so I feel that
it was a good decision to do this
detailed coverage um on the other note
I'd like to mention that in the next
couple of days i will post the of course
the daily blitz games and i will also do
on a daily a 15-minute game for the next
couple of days and starting on next
tuesday this is june third there will be
another super tournament the norway
chess tournament with your champion
magnus carlsen involved plus a chronic
and I
and all the the top guys so i will do a
daily coverage for this tournament
starting tuesday third yeah tuesday
thought um until that I will do the
Blitz and and rapid stuff but then i
will do some some top burn top-level
game coverage okay i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching